les arts ménagers de l'année 1957
nous avons fait assister à une sorte
d'apothéose nous avons vu des nouveautés
qui nous laisse tes blues en fait il ya
du nickel partout jamais les
constructeurs n'avait poussé si loin le
souci de nous rendre facile agréable et
même amusant tous les gestes de la vie
quotidienne
il est besoin une robe du temps de notre
foi sont andy rihs tilman enfouis dans
la mémoire aux mauvais souvenirs nous
avons vu des frigidaires où l'on
aimerait pouvoir finir ses jours après
s'être fait naturaliser la peau nous
avons eu des cuisinières si confortable
dans les fours sont si confortable
qu'ils nous font regretter de n'être pas
nous-mêmes tarte aux prunes et dans le
monde entier est née une saine émulation
d'ailleurs les plus infimes ustensiles
sont l'objet si j'ose dire de la
sollicitude des spécialistes ainsi donné
à new york
on peut trouver une brosse habits dont
le dessus forme boîte pour contenir les
boutons de manchette à rio-de-janeiro on
trouve des saves auront dans lequel
était passé un cordon souple du pire
mais d'accord d'accrocher le savon
robinet de la baignoire ou de le
suspendre autour du cou après avoir
glissé le portrait d'un être cher à
londres on vend des savons en forme de
scaphandrier avec casque au plastique et
tubes de caoutchouc qui plonge et qui
remonte à la surface à volonté les
magasins de copenhague présente un mixte
un mix est un mixeur pardon messieurs à
deux vitesses qui en plus de ses
applications habituelles dross les
chaussures poli d'argenterie peine les
pommes de terre et percer des trous dans
les murs mais les quincailliers de rome
offre des études noir centre où on fait
pas encore très bien à quoi ça peut
servir
mais nul doute qu'un séjour on trouvera
et n'oublions pas surtout la fameuse
cuisine de l'an 2000 la cuisine de
l'avenir ou vraiment tout a atteint un
point de perfection absolument inouïe le
gigot lui-même répond au téléphone pour
vous dire à quelle heure exactement il
sera points après avoir énuméré toutes
ces raisons que nous avons d'être
émerveillé n'en sommes que plus à l'aise
pour exprimer messieurs un regret
jusqu'à présent on n'a encore rien fait
pour l'assiette l'assiette est un objet
ridicule fragile encombrants et démodé
je sais je sais on dira que le problème
a déjà passionné les professionnels et
qu'ils ont mis à notre disposition par
exemple des assiettes en matière
plastique a bien sûr elles sont
incassables
s'il faut tout de même les laver les
spécialistes ont mis aussi à notre
discours
mission l'assiette en carton qui est si
pratique pour les campeurs en ce sens
qu'on peut l'abandonner après usage
n'est ce pas mais elles laissent des
pique niques passer un souvenir assez
écoeurant on pourrait sans doute
remettre à l'honneur les qu elle du
moyen-âge taille et a même dans le droit
de l'attaqué mais il faudrait l'avez
vous prenez enfin quoi bon revenir en
arrière en ont la solution était
ailleurs
la solution était ailleurs et elle a été
trouvée par quelqu'un bien connu dans
d'autres spécialités pharma dame louise
de vilmorin
oui madame louise de vilmorin a trouvé
une solution
et ce sont les prototypes de ces
nouvelles ici que nous allons vous
présenter aujourd'hui en avant-première
à la boîte à sel vous voyez en ce moment
un couple de français moyens
parvenu au terme de son repas ce couple
et d'entrain à curgies tu es une modeste
compote pour le premier monstration bien
sûr nous aurions aimé utiliser un
dessert plus fastueux mais les temps
sont difficiles et les économies
préconisées par monsieur ramadier nous
oblige pas lésiné quelque peu sur
l'accessoire de toute façon la question
n'est pas là nous vous prions maintenant
d'ouvrir tout grand vos yeux car nous
arrivons au point culminant de notre
démonstration l'assiette de madame de
vilmorin ne laisse aucune trace
elle ne demande pas à être lavé elle est
comestible
dès que vous avez fini de dîner vous
mangez votre assiette
elle étend gaufrettes à la vanille pour
les petites filles au chocolat pour les
papas ainsi que l'indiquent madame de
vilmorin si vous n'avez plus faim vous
la donner au chien
et si vous n'avez pas de chien vous
l'aimiez t pour nourrir les oiseaux les
personnes charitables pourront aussi
faire manger leurs assiettes sales par
des pauvres l'assiette vilmorin et
légère à l'estomac et n'empêche pas de
goûter aux autres mets du menu comme
dirait monsieur alan le spirituel
chansonnier une assiette comme ça il n'y
a pas de quoi en faire un plat
désormais l'expression manger une
assiette anglaise prendra toute sa
signification et bientôt nous entendrons
les mères de famille dire à leurs
enfants vous ne quitterez pas la table
avant d'avoir fini votre assiette
rien n'empêche bien sûr d'étendre les
bienfaits de cette heureuse innovation
au couvert lui même bientôt on pourra
manger aussi
la cuillère vivant on pourra manger sa
cuillère car elle est en biscuit huit
ans biscuits à la cuiller forcément plus
nous avons pensé aussi aux gros mangeur
à ceux qui ont tant de mal à se mettre
au régime
et bien cela mangeront leur couteau
voilà ils ont ainsi l'appétit
définitivement coupé l'assiette
commerciaux et donc la précieuse
auxiliaires des médecins l'ami des
familles et des sportifs est le
simplifie la vie est bien l'assiette qui
se mange ne peut manquer dans très
bientôt dans les moeurs et d'entrée
aussi dans nos maisons
on n'arrête pas le progrès aussi dès
aujourd'hui fête commune
débarrassez-vous intérieur vos wc lier
vos armoires de ces objets encombrants
fragile et démodé
si vous avez le bonheur d'être à table
en ce moment n'hésitez pas rejoignez
votre prono
allez les enfants sourit jocelyne et vos
parents à débarrasser la table allait
casser tout fait place nette et des
buffets vous décidiez vos placards
casser la vaisselle
si vous n'avez pas le temps de tout
casser chez vous nous vous rappelons
notre adresse télévision française que
des cognacs dre paris 7e apportez-nous
de votre avis elle et nous ferons une
joie de voir un plaisir aussi brisé nous
mène